Here's a question for you. What is it that makes us most human? Is it our
opposable thumbs? Is it walking on two feet? Well, I would argue, it's the
brain, its overall size and structure. Now, the brain has not always looked
like this. 3 million years ago with the first humans, habilis, it was much
smaller. And then, we had erectus, and then we had neandethal, and in the last
200,000 years we've had us, modern humans, or homo sapiens. And the thing that
really has changed across these different species is the frontal lobe, right
here. It's bigger, it's more complex. And it's the frontal lobes that really do
make us human. It's where we think abstractly, it's where we have working
memory, think about the past and the future. And, we're creative. And it's that
creativity saw first or long ago in the, the cave paintings, and we continue to
see, currently, in modern society, to expose of creativity. Art, science,
music, dance, and so on. So, I would argue, it's the brain that makes us most
human.